[Music]
i have never been witness
to such a silly soft
sam alone
kiss your butt good
happy turkey day everyone my name is
mark ellis and welcome to an all new
episode of rt essentials the show where
we run down the necessary viewing
experiences you need to put in your
eyeballs right now and today we're
getting stuck with tv get your mind out
of the gutter guys and put it on the
sweet sweet yams of the best
thanksgiving television whether you
spend the day with friends and family or
in front of the small screen tv
inevitably plays a big part of the
holiday that most of us will be spending
in a food coma and it's also made for
some great episodes of television the
best of which you guessed it we're
running down today so whether you like
your side stuffed with satire like south
park or you're gravy with some grubby
toss like the west wing we got you
covered so sit back put on your best
stretchy pants and prepare to be stuffed
with great tv
the one with all the thanksgivings
friends
nice try
wait wait wait
look monica
this is not gonna work
but this will work
the mother of all clip shows with a
twist while holiday season usually meant
tv episodes would slack off and play
clips from older seasons to allow cast
and crew a break friends pulled overtime
with their 1998 special the one with all
the thanksgivings instead of showing
clips from past seasons the friends dug
into their old days for some brand new
content that meant scenes with ross and
chandler and mullets and members only
jackets joey running around with a
turkey on his head monica in a fat suit
and rachel with a different nose really
the only one to come out of this
unscathed was phoebe but not only did
thanksgiving establish some of what we
consider the most iconic imagery from
the show the two types of people in the
world are the ones who hear friends and
think of the gang dancing in a fountain
and then there's the ones who hear
friends and see someone wearing a turkey
on their head it also fleshed out a ton
of red con cannon you know what i just
had it with high school boys they're
just
silly they're just silly stupid boys i'm
gonna start dating men
uh
i'm sorry judy i couldn't find that ball
you and jack were looking for
call them mom and dad you loser
considering we were already five seasons
in it was pretty revelatory to find out
how many game-changing moments in the
friend's personal history occurred on
thanksgiving from chandler's dad coming
out of the closet to an obese monica
losing weight and becoming a chef due to
off-handed clips made by chandler while
home with ross from college in 1987 to
the following year's botched revenge
attempt where chandler lost a toe yeah
there's a lot of chandler themed drama
in this episode but there's also the
hilariously horrifying incident with
joey getting a turkey stuck on his head
the backstory on rachel's nose job
ross's first inkling that his ex-wife
carol might be gay all of which
culminates in the present day when
chandler accidentally blurts out i love
you to monica for the first time while
she's wearing a turkey on her head
obviously it's really saying something
that phoebe gets off so easy considering
she spends the day reliving
thanksgivings of her past lives which
were spent on the battlefields of the
civil and the first world war could it
be any more traumatizing the one with
all the thanksgiving set the new gold
standard for holiday specials instead of
bottle episodes which would have
characters sitting in one room queuing
up old clips to save money on production
shows were now pressed to come up with
new ways to subvert the format community
30 rock rick and morty doctor who scrubs
and it's always sunny in philadelphia
are just a few shows that have used that
friends thanksgiving model to subvert
audience expectations and keep them from
tuning out when a character says hey
remember that time we all did that thing
and then it's an old clip no it's going
to be brand new
parents new girl this is my mom hi
this is everybody hi oh come on over i
just want to give you all a big hug oh
come on big thanksgiving hug come on
we'll do a big hug ball come on come on
cece you know how to do this yeah you in
the white shirt i don't do hog rolls
come on in hug ball jump in hug ball
oh dear god
a hug ball dad oh hello bob you're early
you know what i'm thankful for today
divorce in the season two thanksgiving
episode of new girl zoe deschanel's jess
tries to parent-trap her divorced mom
and dad into reconnecting over gravy
while thanksgiving stories are usually
about going home for the holidays new
girl spices things up by having gene and
bob come over to jessa's loft which she
shares with three male roommates with
their own laundry list of idiosyncratic
quirks the absolute best of which has to
be jake johnson's nick miller the most
dudeliest of the guys and just his
future love interest who reluctantly
agrees with the plan only to find
himself falling for jess's mom gene
celebrities showing up for
holiday-themed cameos are to tv what
stuffing and green bean casseroles are
to turkey they're classic staples
catherine cheated
yeah oh bob that's terrible i'm so sorry
no really i had no idea yeah well yeah
oh sorry really come here come here let
me just give you guys salmonella
together with the salmonella yeah i
liked her you did no i didn't think so
no again
hey
remember that song
new girl was no exception landing
rom-com veterans jamie lee curtis and
rob reiner for gene and bob and though
it's not quite stunt casting there are a
few cute connections curtis is married
to christopher guest who reiner directed
in this spinal tap curtis also played
the mom in freaky friday which he
co-starred in alongside parent trap alum
lindsay lohan reiner also rose to fame
with his role as the son-in-law meathead
of archie bunker's family and norman
lears all in the family pop culture
dictionary tvtropes.com literally lists
on the family under their definition of
dysfunctional family calling the show
the template of tv depictions as well as
deliberate subversion of them which is
the perfect description of this new girl
episode where jess's parents obviously
do not get back together but do hook up
in a bathroom at one point
ah thanksgiving
hangs buffy the vampire slayer
slaughtered my people
now you kill their spirit
this is a great day for you
buffy the vampire slayer took a
supernatural tack to the holidays in
season four's pangs in which the scooby
crew has to fend off the spirit of a
chumash warrior named hoos considering
the episode came out in 1999 pre-y2k you
might expect it to be a tone-deaf
portrayal of indigenous culture but
pangs didn't shy away from the harsh
reality hiding behind the pilgrim hats
and pumpkin pie stories hoost dispatches
the descendants of sunnydale's violent
settlers by cursing him the way his
tribe was dispatched cutting the ears
off of some and causing xander to come
down with simultaneous cases of smallpox
syphilis and malaria no it's not pretty
but that was typical slayer's style gory
with a side of social commentary
atrocities i got the full poop on the
shumash indians in our
fabulous buried mission you said you
were gonna get fresh ones atrocities
peas they come little pods you were
gonna shell them i didn't have time i i
was busy reading about the shoe my schwa
too much was peaceful
oh they were peaceful all right they
were fluffy indigenous kittens till we
came along this episode was
controversial in the way it tackled race
particularly because it drew from
reality the chumash tribe once resided
alongside the coast of santa barbara
with a population estimated to be around
20 000 before european settlers arrived
they also still exist today in much
smaller numbers on a reservation in
santanes california and while some have
pointed that hoos acts like western
stereotypes of native americans other
critics have called it a medic critique
with characters including buffy acting
like a black hat cliche from old
westerns helen keller the musical south
park i want you all to meet jeffrey
maynard he's south park's biggest expert
on musical theater and he played the
lead in les miserables at the denver
community playhouse for five weeks
do you think we can make up a good
thanksgiving play in four days i would
swear it on my life your play shall want
for nothing
now the first thing any good musical
needs is a big opening number something
that sets up the entire show all right
places everybody bring in the turkey
what the hell is that as you'd expect
south park took one look at the
touchy-feely direction of most
thanksgiving episodes and said yeah
that's a hard pass instead trey parker
and matt stone drew inspiration from
their theater geek obsession in season
four of the show to create a new
tradition for the town of south park
helen keller the musical both the title
of the show and the episode are almost
identical down to the punctuation to one
of the comedy duo's first films 1993's
cannibal the musical it's no accident
the kids in the show are all forced to
wear fake beards that are replicas of
the ones worn by stone and parker in
their dark comedy based on the true
story of a colorado wilderness
expedition in 1887
that went terribly wrong in cannibal the
grimm's story is buoyed by light-hearted
tunes like spidoykel in helen keller the
inspirational legacy of the miracle
worker is reimagined as a thanksgiving
extravaganza to beat that of the
kindergarten class as described by
butter they hire a local community
theater actor fresh off a stint as jean
valjean in a denver production of les
miz who sings all of his lines in a
direct send up of colm wilkinson but
before hugh jackman came along was the
jean valjean de beast
all right everybody let's take our
places cartman where's timmy's turkey i
don't know
i don't know you guys all right maybe i
tried to have timmy's turkey crushed by
a stage light but i didn't do anything
else i'm not
you're going to be brilliant you sexy
gorgeous turkey with that other meddling
animal out of the way you'll steal the
show
this is timmy's story though timmy and
his turkey gobbles who having invaded a
murderous turkey trainer the
slaughterhouse and the bullet of the
town's hunters saved the play by going
on stage and jumping through a ring of
fire parker and stone have said in
interviews that this episode was their
version of a charlie brown thanksgiving
special a surprisingly heartfelt tale of
a boy and his pet the fact that the
episode also has homages to the right
stuff and the godfather are just the
dollop of whipped cream on top of the
pumpkin pie
thanksgiving master of none oh yeah i
know it makes erica she's cute
i like her
i have a crush on her
wait are you trying to tell me that
you're
you know
lebanese
wait you're from lebanon no i just i
don't know how to i'm not comfortable
with the word uh
lesbian
all right so we'll say you're lebanese
the netflix series master of none
tackled some hard truths in 2017 with
their season 2 holiday episode
appropriately titled thanksgiving
instead of focusing on aziz ansari's dev
we follow the trajectory of denise
played by co-writer lena waite over the
years that she grappled with her
sexuality and how to come out to her
mother catherine played by angela
bassett i'm just gonna take this out
thank you
i think this is gonna be a lovely
thanksgiving denise yeah i think so
and uh i like michelle
i like her too
i'm happy for you
the full arc from denise is a young girl
in her bedroom realizing she's attracted
to girls coming out as lebanese to dev
biting the bullet and revealing the news
to her mother in a diner the subsequent
disastrous attempts at bringing home
dates for the holiday and the family's
eventual reconciliation with denise's
sexuality was a trailblazing episode of
tv that really was a product of its time
it's no coincidence that the episode
aired the year after barry jenkins
moonlight another meditation of black
queerness won best picture at the oscars
thanksgiving also walked away with
accolades winning outstanding writing in
a comedy at the emmys where wait made
history as the first black woman to ever
receive the award
thanksgiving orphans cheers i'm sorry
guys a little pop thing won't pop out
there's nothing wrong with it i there's
something wrong with you no no it's a
little pop thing hey could somebody
please explain to me where the little
pop thing is on the turkey i mean cause
maybe it's different in the city but in
the country where i come from turkey's
unborn with little pop
the little pop thing has a name it's
called a thermometer now can we all
please say thermometer
if you've ever thought to yourself gee
life is pretty good but you know what
would make it better if i could just see
woody harrelson struggling to get out of
a headlock while covered in yams at ted
danson fraser and the guy from the pixar
movies are there too just completely
losing their minds pelting ice-cold
mashed potatoes at each other gravy
dripping down their hair faces contorted
with rage like lord of the flies but
with grown-ups i want to see the facade
of civilization momentarily dropped and
laugh as i witness these well-regarded
actors devolve into their most primal
animalistic instincts then boy do i have
a cheers episode for you in 1986
thanksgiving orphans premiered in the
middle of cheers his fifth season and
honestly we're still a little shook from
all that we witnessed the premise is
simple carla played by ria pearlman
invites the gang from the bar over for a
potluck thanksgiving and along with a
raw turkey and rapidly cooling side
dishes everyone brings a heaping bag of
their own well baggage
norm i'm sorry about what i said about
your gravy all right it's okay
[Music]
and so are the carrots
anybody want some of these uh little
bitty yams
when carla and norm start sniping at
each other the scene erupts into a
chaotic food fight the likes of which
have never been seen on tv before or
since it's truly out of control and it
feels like you're watching these people
have some sort of violent cathartic
breakthrough whether it was the actors
themselves doing a really good job
tapping into their characters or just
actual animosity being worked out in
front of a live studio audience we'll
never know but it is some great
occasionally cringe-worthy television
director james burrows did two tanks of
the food fight scene which had only been
choreographed up until the moment where
sam throws cranberry sauce in diane's
face the extended takes meant the forest
had to be covered with pink tarp causing
the actors to continuously slip on the
accumulated food gunk and the smell was
apparently not great after the episode
aired angry letters were sent in by
viewers who said the episode promoted
wasting food during a time when world
hunger was the political cause du jour
which burroughs responded to claiming
all the uneaten leftovers were donated
to a charity food bank
slapsgiving how i met your mother sent
you something
what is it just a new website
slapcountdown.com
what does this mean marshall
[Music]
no
no
we never condone violence especially on
the holidays but for barney well we'll
make an exception as portrayed by neil
patrick harris on how i met your mother
barney is all smarm no bite as evidenced
in 2007's slaps giving during season
three in this episode marshall uses his
third out of five free slaps he won from
barney barney claiming that marshall
tipped his hand in naming the
get-together slapsgiving as the most
excruciating part of the slap is a
suspense of not knowing when and where
it might happen i've invented a new
holiday slapsgiving it's the one day we
set aside each year to gather together
and give slaps you're gonna slap me on
thanksgiving slapsgiving
that's not allowed lily you're the
slapbit commissioner is that allowed the
hostess in me who's using her wedding
china for the first time wants to say
hell no
but yeah i've got all that marshall
throws down the exact time 301 pm on
thanksgiving day he's got a countdown
timer and everything after watching her
husband torture barney about it all day
slap back commissioner willy calls the
event off but barney's crowing annoys
her into reinstating it three seconds
before the clock runs out marshall slaps
barney so hard it spins him around
knocks him over and then proceeds to
lead the group into a song around the
piano you just got slapped all's well
that slaps well but at least until next
year when slapsgiving could make its
return it certainly will in my family
fans of forgetting sarah marshall and
the muppets may not be surprised to
learn that siegel not only played the
piano and sang you just got slapped but
compose the song himself we'd expect
nothing less from the guy who brought us
dracula the musical die die die i can't
the gang squashes their beef it's always
sunny in philadelphia hey i have an idea
it's time now to wipe the slate clean no
no you said we were gonna do the hatchet
thing first don't worry about the
hatchet thing that was an unsanctioned
move well none of these moves are
working we gotta do something else
it's always sunny in philadelphia isn't
a show that's exactly known for its
kindness most episodes tend to focus on
the most awful instincts of the gang of
d frank charlie mack and dennis and how
their toxicity bleeds into those around
them characters who started the series
as straight man foils to the zany
residents of paddy's pub have slid down
a steep slope morally ethically
socioeconomically and many times
grotesquely physically as well like
cricket who we first met as a priest who
had a crush on d in high school before a
rekindling of dee's interest sent him
spiraling until he was unemployed
homeless with open wounds a limp leg and
an absolute lack of shame so viewers
could be forgiven for being a little
suspicious when the thanksgiving episode
of season nine was titled the gang
squashes their beasts
i've got an idea
[Music]
so we're just gonna lock them in there
they're definitely gonna burn to death
okay guys nobody's gonna burn all right
there's a fire escape we'll call 9-1-1
we just need to buy a little time so we
can get the hell out of here i feel like
we're just creating more beefs which we
will not resolve beefs are best left
simmering under the surface i've learned
that now best thing to do with the beef
jam it deep down inside and then press
forward after realizing their rivalries
had cost them the ability to shop at
wawa rent from the video store or heat
their apartment they devise a plan to
repair all their broken relationships in
one fell swoop bringing all their
enemies under one roof for a
thanksgiving dinner to end all dinners
with an epic apology but because it's
always sunny the gang's attempt to make
amends end with them starting a fire
inside dennis and max apartment sealing
everyone inside don't worry dennis tells
the gang there's a fire escape and
they'll just go to a different movie
store and wawa the gang ends up watching
their favorite movie thunder gun express
at frank and charlie's apartment believe
it or not this is more of an uplifting
ending than we usually get on that show
the episode is a treasure trove of
easter eggs from previous seasons
returning fan favorite characters like
jimmy simpson as the cycloptic half of
the pair of creepy mcpoyle brothers and
mary lynn raysgov as dee and dennis's
creepy mouth-breathing cousin gail the
snail there's also sad sac creep bill
ponderosa the aforementioned homeless
creep rickety cricket and frank's creepy
landlord hwang yeah pretty much everyone
in this world is a super creep but what
can you expect from a show where our
ostensible protagonist keeps trying to
get the table to sign weird documents
that absolve him of any actual
wrongdoing without ever offering an
apology
a deep-fried korean thanksgiving gilmore
girls
he's shamelessly catering to his
demographic are you right
oh my god i can't look nine hey oh my
god they're counting down
it's in the bat it's like a death in the
family look at the bright side suki at
least this took your mind off to dinner
at the end for a show about a single mom
and her daughter the gilmore girls was
often as talky as it was feely and that
was no different in the season three
episode a deep fried korean thanksgiving
focusing as much on the tension between
lorelei and rory after the former finds
out her daughter got into yale without
telling her as well as the big pain in
the butt family can be the twosome is
forced to attend not one not two but
four separate thanksgivings yeah it
sounds like the plot of a classic
stovetop commercial or that reese
witherspoon and vince vaughn rom-com yes
four christmases
i was a fan oh mrs kim just a beautiful
table as always try the tofurky turkey
made from tofu oh it definitely will and
meet the guitar player nice young man
big fan of tofurky david yes this is roy
gilmour and this is gilmore hi nice to
meet you oh sam here i think i've seen
you around town yeah that might be a
possibility happy thanksgiving it also
served as a chance for creator amy
sherman palladino to showcase some of
the trademark clips and sly references
such as a character playing a david
bowie song before a hymn or laura lyon
rory starting the episode watching grey
gardens a documentary that paints a
pretty terrifying portrait of what
living alone with your mother for too
long can do for your sanity and social
life something the ready to lead the
nest rory is discovering besides the
hell that can be family holidays this
episode is also notable as the first
time that dave and lane kiss
ah
love
an indecent family proposal bob's
burgers huh i thought the kitchen would
be more uh mansiony mansions are for the
owners bob not the cooks now if you'll
excuse me i'm going to get drunk for
dinner do you mean dressed dressed out
of my mind gotta loosen up you know
right right gotta get my sex face on i
can't wait to see it
well lynn this might not be so bad right
this thanksgiving
what my hair now i gotta go redo it
great fine guess i'll just be here alone
with the
with the turkey my name's lance sorry
with lance an animated night of fake
families absinthe life-saving turkeys
and kevin klein in an eye patch bob's
burgers outdid itself with its season
three stunner an indecent family
proposal the name says it all the
belcher's landlord mr deschoder voiced
by klein comes to his tenants asking if
they'd pretend to be his family to make
an old flame jealous but in their desire
to impress sharpshooter shelley the
family forgets bob who gets drunk on
absinthe and befriends his now
anthropomorphic turkey lance who he's
been hired to cook
[Music]
[Music]
this is weird
right when he freaks out at his family
for abandoning their annual traditions
lance ends up taking the bullet for him
literally after shelley mistakes his
outburst for the deranged rantings of a
disgruntled employee and shoots him
all's well that ends well as the
belchers realize how much family
tradition is important to their
patriarch and used the next day as a
thanksgiving do-over unfortunately lance
doesn't make it but on the bright side
he was never alive to begin with bob's
burgers is a show known for its great
musical parodies my personal favorite is
still the ode to cotton candy done to
the tune of don't you forget about me
but few have been turned into actual
radio pop tunes the thanksgiving song
which was improvised on the spot by john
roberts was such a bop it was later
covered by the band the national it's
impossible to resist the catchy refrain
kill kill kill the turkey
samantha's thanksgiving to remember be
whipped we'll tell you all about the
first thanksgiving
it was a blast
we ate for three days
you were there
i guess of course
oh what memories
the pilgrims
plymouth rock
mile standish
priscilla
john alden
boston blackie
[Music]
no that's not cut right now the
thanksgiving we were taught about in
school isn't necessarily the one we
celebrate today for a variety of reasons
that a pop culture show isn't
necessarily the right platform to
address but for a long time the image of
settlers breaking bread and corn on the
maze with the indigenous population of
north america was the image we like to
think about when imagining the holiday
but there is at least one early example
of a show that broke the mold and
confronted some of the more unsavory
elements of american history that show
bewitched despite lasting eight seasons
season four samantha's thanksgiving to
remember was the only episode of the
series to feature the holiday and
actually aired on turkey day with a
sobering message
this is plymouth
17th century plymouth yes isn't it
exciting
we got to get out of here they burned
witches in the 17th century the ones
they thought were witches not the real
ones
the big witch hysteria didn't start
until much later well i don't like even
a little rich hysteria in the episode
samantha and friends travel back to 17th
century massachusetts during the heated
era of witch hunts samantha meets famous
pilgrim john alden played by richard
bull and darren is put on trial for
being a warlock the episode becomes a
meditation on tolerance of those who are
different from us as samantha gives a
rousing defense speech for darren about
the dangers of using others as
scapegoats for our own insecurities wow
maybe she could have time traveled to
the future to give us that message huh
it was no accident that the episode
sounded a lot like arthur miller's the
crucible like miller the writers of a
thanksgiving to remember married couple
alfred lewis leavitt and wife helen
sloat levitt had both been blacklisted
from hollywood after alfred was
subpoenaed to testify in front of the
house on american activities committee
in 1951 labeled a communist neither was
able to work for five years and when
they returned to the small screen they
now went under the surname august under
the cheery veneer of bewitched
samantha's thanksgiving to remember was
as much a commentary on mccarthyism as
it was arthur miller's play
and with that we wrap up our best
thanksgiving tv and send you home with
all the leftovers we're just nice like
that and if you've still got a hankering
for great movie tv and pop culture
content head on over to
rottentomatoes.com where we keep our
fridge well stocked on news reviews and
original features about the stuff you
care about this has been rt essentials
i'm mark ellis signing off so i can go
digest take a nap and then come back for
thirds of pumpkin pie but stick around
we've got more great programming coming
your way so stay tuned and as always
gobble gobble
[Music]
you